-So happy you're here.
Congratulations on the film.
It's getting wonderful reviews.
-It is. Yes.
-I keep hearing how funny it is.
The title is "Blockers," but
the posters lead you to believe
there's more to the title.
-Yeah, that's, like, a --
You know, like, a cute graphic.
You know how they sometimes
will put, like,
cute puppies or kittens
on things?
And that's just
kind of overused?
And they just decided to put
a little -- cute little chicken.
-'Cause teens --
they say that teens --
Chickens often poll as
the cutest animal among teens.
But this is about three --
We saw you, John Cena,
and Ike Barinholtz
are parents of three girls...
-Yes.
-...who have a prom pact.
-Mm-hmm.
A prom pact to lose
their virginity.
-Yeah.
-And -- Yes.
And so we, the parents,
find out about this
and we do everything
we can to stop that,
because we think
it's a bad idea.
-Did this bring back any
personal memories of your prom?
-You know, it's so weird,
because the kids today --
You know, people say like,
"Oh, kids today --
they're so, like,
you know, fast."
And I think it's the opposite.
I think that, you know, they're,
like, so sweet and they, like,
mostly just talk on the phone
or FaceTime or whatever.
And back in my day,
we, like, got together.
And...you know, we weren't
slutty, but we were not --
We were, like --
We were, like, easy.
-...er.
-You were easier.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were kind enough to
bring your prom photo.
-Yes.
-And I'm so proud of you
for being willing to show this.
-[ Laughs ]
-But it's amazing.
It's not -- I don't know.
It's just kind of perfect.
It is the best.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...now, you grew up in --
-Newport Beach.
-Yeah.
-And, by the way, that's the
only place this could be from.
When you drive into
Newport Beach,
this is the billboard.
That's fantastic.
Did you have
a nice time at your prom?
-Yes.
I had a nice time with him.
He's not my type at all.
-Well, you're married to
Judd Apatow.
-Yeah.
-And that's not Judd Apatow.
[ Laughter ]
-He's, like, 6'5", and he has,
like, very broad shoulders,
like, hard to the touch.
-Uh-huh.
-And --
-The way you're touching this,
we might have to call him
and get consent.
-No hair.
He had no
body hair, which I'm not into.
-Oh, wow.
-Do you see my finger?
-I don't see your finger.
-It's missing.
-Oh, my God.
-Wait. Do you see that?
-Why do you have
a missing finger?
-So, I...
[ Laughter ]
So, I slammed my finger
in a chair,
and it turned black and blue
and the fingernail fell off.
So I thought like,
"Oh, I'll just cover it up."
-That's way more natural.
That's way more natural.
And, like, the crazy thing is,
kids today --
they might be less sluttier,
but they would be able to, like,
Photoshop in the finger.
-Right. Exactly.
-That's what they do with
all the time that, you know,
people our age
were bangin' in high school.
[ Laughter ]
They do, like, Photoshop.
They put filters on stuff.
-You guys,
my kids are backstage.
[ Laughter ]